[Música]
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos de visual política estoy
convencido de que no voy a tener que
hacer ningún esfuerzo para convenceros
de que latinoamérica es una de las
regiones más inseguras y convulsas del
mundo
[Música]
desgraciadamente la violencia y el
crimen han hecho que algunas zonas de
latinoamérica sean un lugar peligroso
hablamos todos lo sabéis de una región
que ha sido fuertemente golpeada por el
tráfico de estupefacientes el tráfico de
armas y otras tantas actividades
ilegales que se han desarrollado sin que
los estados hayan podido o hayan querido
tampoco nos engañemos poner remedio a
esta situación
aunque sea algo difícil de entender
muchos grupos criminales han construido
nexos lazos conexiones vínculos
extremadamente cercanos con muchos
gobiernos e instituciones públicas de la
región incluso en algunos casos estos
grupos son capaces de influir controlar
y dirigir gobiernos enteros sin ir más
lejos hace muy poco aquí en visual
político hablamos del caso de
centroamérica pero amigos hay otro país
que no podemos pasar por alto y que en
los últimos años ha cogido la delantera
hasta convertirse tal vez en el país no
en guerra más peligroso del planeta
estoy hablando por supuesto de la
venezuela de nicolás maduro
[Música]
si no creo que venezuela es el poder
popular y el poder popular de vestir
aprendo y pendiente
[Música]
y es que no es nada nuevo sin ir más
lejos ya os hablamos aquí en visual
político sobre cómo venezuela se está
convirtiendo a la velocidad del rayo en
toda una narco dictadura pero
desgraciadamente ahí no queda todo en la
venezuela de hoy la delincuencia y el
crimen organizado campan a sus anchas
hasta tal punto que si el crimen se
reduce no es extraño pensar que simple y
llanamente porque cada vez hay menos
cosas que roban casi 30.000 30.000
víctimas mortales que se conozcan cada
año en un país no en guerra 130 mil
muertes violentas tan solo en los
últimos cinco años con datos qué
barbaridad
[Música]
el caso es que tal y como podéis ver en
pantalla tanto la tasa de homicidios
conocida como el número de muertes
violentas comenzaron a reducirse en 2017
extraño teniendo en cuenta que el país
está peor que nunca tanto económica como
socialmente no os parece y si ya sé que
alguno de vosotros seguro que estará
pensando claro obvio eso es por toda la
inmigración que ha padecido venezuela
más de 4 millones de personas - cientos
y cientos de miles millones de jóvenes
menos es algo que se tendría que notar
lo que nos ha tocado salir prácticamente
exiliado queremos que vuelva a la
justicia venezuela y la libertad pues
amigos sí y no con matices en este vídeo
vamos a hablar de los efectos que el
crimen ha causado en venezuela hablamos
de un crimen institucionalizado y
causado en buena medida desde el propio
gobierno
y también nos vamos a contar como la
delincuencia ha llegado a tales niveles
que a los delincuentes comunes ya ni
siquiera le sale rentable delinquir en
venezuela haciendo que muchos busquen
oportunidades fuera si tal cual como lo
escucháis atentos
los malos al poder lo primero de todo es
ponerse en situación en un país digamos
normal lo común es que un gobierno
combata el crimen y se dedique a
perseguir a los malos verdad bueno pues
en venezuela no es así aquí nos
encontramos con el fenómeno opuesto los
malos son los que gobiernan fijaos
tareck el aissami eeuu incluye al
ministro de venezuela en la lista de los
10 más buscados por narcotráfico
internacional un juez español investiga
a medio gobierno de maduro por lavar
dinero del petróleo sorprendidos bueno
seguro que los que seguís visual polític
desde hace tiempo no lo estaréis tanto
seguro que habéis visto ya nuestro vídeo
sobre cómo venezuela se ha convertido en
un narcoestado y si aún no lo habéis
visto os dejo el enlace abajo en la
descripción el caso es que ya poco o
nada nos puede sorprender de este país
sin embargo si hay una cosa que sigue
sorprendiéndonos como el régimen
chavista ha conseguido hacerse con el
monopolio de la delincuencia callejera
maduro pidió ayuda a grupos afines para
defender la paz tal cual como lo
escucháis el gobierno venezolano tiene
literalmente a miles de delincuentes a
sueldo delincuentes que en muchos casos
han sido armados por el propio estado
para que funcionen como grupos
parapoliciales de represión política
hablamos de los llamados colectivos
los colectivos son grupos que se
movilizan a petición del gobierno
especialmente cuando hay protestas de
opositores
entonces se mueven con motos y armas
largas que disparan a todo lo que se
mueve todo con absoluta impunidad y
mientras la policía y la guardia
nacional bolivariana les miran
totalmente impasibles es más muchos
casos incluso actúan conjuntamente
de esta forma es como en venezuela- la
violencia ha sido totalmente controlada
por el estado pero no para acabar con
ella sino para monopolizar la y usarla
contra los ciudadanos opositores
y no no os penséis que esto es todo
además de los colectivos de la muerte
que es como se los conoce popularmente
los mismísimos cuerpos de seguridad del
estado bueno de seguridad por decir algo
actúan como auténticos criminales para
que os hagáis una idea según los datos
aportados por la onu casi siete mil
siete mil personas perdieron la vida por
resistencia a la autoridad entre enero
de 2018 y mayo de 2019 es decir en poco
más de un año siete mil ejecuciones
extrajudiciales procesan a 464 policías
en venezuela por delitos de extorsión y
secuestro vamos que en venezuela tal y
como veis la delincuencia está a todos
los niveles y eso es lo que explica que
en buena parte quede impune cuando hasta
la policía es en muchos casos cómplice
mal asunto 92% de los homicidios que
ocurren en venezuela quedan impunes y
ojo todo esto no es algo que digamos
solamente en visual político para nada
es algo que incluso también afirman
michelle bachelet la alta comisionada de
la onu para los derechos humanos en su
informe sobre venezuela
mi oficina ha seguido documentando casos
de posibles ejecuciones extrajudiciales
cometidas por miembros de las fuerzas de
acción especiales de la policía nacional
solo en el pasado mes de julio la
organización no gubernamental monitor de
víctimas identificó 57 nuevos casos de
presuntas ejecuciones cometidas por
miembros del país en caracas
michelle bachelet y desde luego no creo
que me podéis decir por mucho que digan
nicolás maduró que bachelet forma parte
de algún movimiento internacional que
tiene como objetivo perseguir
tendenciosamente al régimen bolivariano
verdad conociendo bachelet sería absurdo
pensarlo
y teniendo en cuenta la situación en
venezuela los testimonios y la
información disponible yo personalmente
creo que se quedó corta lo que tampoco
me sorprende dicho sea de paso el caso
es que esto no es todo
y tengamos que ir a una batalla
definitiva por la paz en venezuela por
la unión nacional vamos a prepararnos
para derrotarlos
junto a los colectivos y las reprobables
actuaciones de los cuerpos de seguridad
del estado han llevado a que en
venezuela se hayan multiplicado también
los delitos a pequeña escala
aquellos que podríamos denominar como
delincuencia por arrastre o incluso
delincuencia por supervivencia
todo ello por no hablar de la corrupción
absolutamente generalizada que reina en
todo el país en la venezuela de hoy para
conseguir documentos oficiales
pasaportes o incluso para lograr
atención médica los sobornos son
totalmente indispensables
y es que claro esto es algo que tiene
fundamentalmente dos razones por un lado
tenemos la pobreza y los salarios
salarios que prácticamente no sirven
para nada la hiperinflación ha hecho que
los salarios locales no alcance para
nada
el nuevo salario mínimo en venezuela
solo alcanza para comprar un cartón de
huevos y claro es natural es
supervivencia
cuando la necesidad aprieta la gente se
aprovecha para intentar rascar algo de
dinero como sea aprovechándose del
descontrol y la impunidad ahora bien
algunos seguro que me diréis pero
alberto no habías dicho antes que los
crímenes y la delincuencia estaban
bajando con este panorama no lo parece
verdad pues fijaos parece complicado
pero lo cierto es que si lo está
haciendo y os vamos a contar porque
atentos porque vienen curvas
[Música]
el poder los productivos que hasta ahora
hemos ensayado y para acá está todo y la
responsabilidad es nuestra es mía es mía
es tuya
[Música]
por qué ser malandro ha dejado de ser
rentable amigos es la triste pero cruda
realidad venezolana las cosas están tan
mal que la crisis ha afectado incluso a
los delincuentes o malandros como se les
conoce en venezuela tasa de homicidios
baja en venezuela en 2018 en parte por
la masiva emigración crisis en venezuela
bajas robos y asaltos delincuentes ya no
pueden pagar balas lo habéis escuchado
bien pensando un momento con una
inflación del doscientos mil por ciento
que es la que pronostica el fmi para
este año de qué sirve robar minucias y
el valor del dinero que vas a poder
conseguir se va a esfumar en apenas unos
días de qué sirve atracar la caja fuerte
de un banco si los bolívares que hay
dentro no valen para nada o de qué sirve
robar coches o motos si es muy difícil
conseguir recambios y si a todo esto le
añadimos el factor inmigración pues la
ecuación está resuelta
[Música]
y parece surrealista y difícil de creer
pero el desastre al que nicolás maduro
está conduciendo a venezuela está
haciendo que miles y miles de
delincuentes busquen nuevos lugares
donde delinquir por así decirlo
venezuela está exportando su propia
delincuencia tal cual venezuela está tan
mal que ni los malandros la quieren
maduro impulso a la salida de criminales
de venezuela y sabéis quiénes son las
principales víctimas de esto si vale la
gente de los países receptores pero
pensad un momento en los 3 millones de
venezolanos que han emigrado
aquí en visual polític no podemos dejar
pasar por alto los efectos que este
fenómeno está teniendo en los
inmigrantes venezolanos en el resto de
latinoamérica porque si dejar atrás a tu
país a tu familia y todo lo que has
conseguido durante años de esfuerzo es
ya de por sí traumático lo que viene a
continuación lo es todavía más fijaos
simplemente yo no quería salir de aquí
el país como digo yo me considero
venezolano por todos los años que tengo
yo amo venezuela pero nos lleva a esta
situación la difícil condición de ser
venezolano en latinoamérica así es
amigos para muchos ser venezolanos ser
venezolana se ha convertido en todo un
reto en algunos países latinoamericanos
os imagináis lo que es tener que
soportar constantes comentarios racistas
o xenófobos o sufrir abusos por parte de
las autoridades solo por ser de un país
en concreto pues todo esto forma parte
del efecto que está teniendo la salida
de delincuentes venezolanos hacia los
países vecinos de esta forma las vidas
de muchos inmigrantes venezolanos que
cumplen las normas son la inmensa
mayoría se están haciendo más difíciles
por su culpa y eso es lo que provoca
cosas como estas trabas burocráticas y
ataques xenófobos contra venezolanos en
américa latina en países como perú por
ejemplo recientemente hemos visto
incluso hasta congresistas como
esther saavedra atacando duramente a los
venezolanos desde el propio congreso
[Música]
la receta
tienen que dormir
poneos en situación os imagináis tener
que huir de una dictadura del hambre y
la violencia y recibir semejantes
insultos por parte de representantes
públicos y va a ser bastante duro no
creéis claro que afortunadamente esta
forma de pensar no representa la de
todos los peruanos ni mucho menos pero
los discursos de odio que señalan a una
nacionalidad son siempre preocupantes y
que se lancen desde el congreso de un
país son aún más y esperad porque esto
esto no se acaba aquí hasta el propio
presidente de ecuador lenín moreno cayó
en las garras de esta campaña tras el
asesinato de una mujer embarazada por
parte de un venezolano 'ecuador anuncia
la creación de brigadas para controlar a
los inmigrantes venezolanos ahora bien
realmente porque en latinoamérica se ha
generado esta oleada de odio a los
venezolanos pues en buena medida tiene
que ver con la falta de cultura
migratoria
tradicionalmente la mayoría de estos
países no han sido receptores de
inmigración y de repente de la noche a
la mañana se produce un éxodo de
venezolanos por todo el continente no
parece descabellado que sean muchos los
que perciban este movimiento con miedo
miedo a lo diferente a lo que viene de
fuera de las consecuencias que puede
tener no creéis y esto es algo que está
pasando incluso en colombia el país
vecino de venezuela ha sido quien más
venezolanos ha acogido más de millón y
medio desde la explosión de la gran
crisis venezolana entre 2014 y 2015 la
proximidad y el hecho de que emigrar de
venezuela-colombia sea lo más barato ha
hecho que muchos delincuentes comunes
venezolanos acaben actuando en colombia
[Música]
desde un primer momento la actitud del
gobierno colombiano ha sido la de ayudar
a la población venezolana abriendo la
frontera otorgando permisos temporales e
incluso aceptando a venezolanos con
pasaportes caducados sin embargo esta
ola de solidaridad a nivel institucional
no siempre se ha replicado al nivel de
la calle ya que colombia se encuentra
junto con perú méjico chile y ecuador
entre los países donde más casos de
xenofobia se denuncian por parte de
venezolanos y cuando nos referimos a
xenofobia hablamos de cosas que están
empezando a surgir como esta denuncian
amenazas en panfletos contra inmigrantes
venezolanos en colombia por supuesto
esta nuez y mucho menos la tónica
mayoritaria y si algo han demostrado las
sociedades latinoamericanas es una
enorme solidaridad al acoger a miles y
miles cientos de miles de venezolanos
que se han visto obligados a huir de su
país
[Música]
si hay que perseguir a los delincuentes
pero no sería justo que pagaran
inocentes por culpables no os parece
además que ese tipo de brotes xenófobos
favorecen a la narco dictadura
venezolana en tanto en cuanto pueden
llegar a reducir la presión sobre el
propio régimen
[Música]
en fin amigos esta es la cruda realidad
de la violencia en venezuela y todos
estos factores son los que explican que
este país se haya convertido en una
auténtica pesadilla pero llegados a este
punto turno para ti se puede luchar
contra la violencia en un país cuyo
gobierno tiene criminales a sueldo deben
los venezolanos en el exterior
enfrentarse a sus compatriotas malandros
para acabar con la xenofobia y todavía
más importante creéis que están
justificados esos comportamientos de
odio contra todos ellos nuestras son las
preguntas vuestras las respuestas muchas
gracias por ver este vídeo y recuerda si
te ha gustado no olvides darle al botón
de like y suscríbete a este canal muchos
más contenidos súper interesantes están
por llegar un saludo y hasta la próxima
que lo que nos ha tocado salir
prácticamente exiliados queremos que
vuelva la justicia venezuela y la
libertad